John: Happy Project for Awesome!
Hank: Woo!!
John: Ba-ohh
Hank: That was disappointing.
John: Don’t worry. I’ve got more, Hank. I’ve got more confetti!
Hank: A little one.
John: Pa-pow!
Oh, it’s the most magical time of the year.
Phil: The only way to go from here is down.
Ettore: I’m one of many Save the Children
employees here, and we have a final parting message.
Stand by for that.
Save the Children Staff: Don’t forget to
be awesome!
Emily: This isn’t—this isn’t my first
rodeo on the Project for Awesome livestream.
Sherrie: Doesn’t he look beautiful today?
Big Bird: We all could stand to be a little
kinder, don’t you think?
Sherrie: Project for Awesome is such an awesome
idea—
Big Bird: Oh, don’t forget to be awesome!
Sherrie: Exactly!
Hank: Take a screenshot. It’ll last longer.
Lindsey: Oh my gosh, it’s so cold!
John: People are calling me Glitter Beard—oh,
it’s ‘cause you want me to put glitter in my beard.
Rhett: Once you fall in love with the em dash—good, woah, buddy—
Link: Good woah buddy
We've already passed $315,000! What!
Hank: How are we all going to die, Phil?
Pat: You’re not better than Times New Roman.
Grace & Mamrie: 1, 2, 3 candle!
OHHH MY GOD!!!
Grace: Prove Hank wrong!
Grace, Mamrie, and Hannah: Prove Hank wrong!
Hank: Well, John just arrived in the chat,
so now everybody’s really excited, and—
Gabby: Wait, you know John Green?
Nathan (Obama): We’re gonna be here in Trump’s
America, we gotta do a couple things.
Sabrina: How does a ragtag volunteer army
in need of a shower somehow defeat a global superpower?
Mamrie: Does it hurt?
Gideon: *sings*
Hank: Okay, going up on my forehead, Kendall.
My kerning was a little off there, Alex.
Lex: Is everyone happy with their kitty time?
Destin: Josh, you are, you are the McCall.
John *reading a question*: So what do you
think of Mars?
John: I think it is a cold, dead rock in the
middle of the ocean.
Charlie: As many bread demon emojis as you
can in the chat.
That will be helpful.
Charlie, Emily, Rosianna: The power of bread
compels you!
John: Oh, Hank, you put up Cheez Doodles Guy!
John: YAAAAASSS!!!
Hank: YES!
Team SciShow: Woo!
Hank: And s fantastic Project for Awesome. I’m so proud of this community.
I’m back!
Thanks for our fabulous tenth ever Project for Awesome. Had a great time.
My mind is still a little bit hungover from
it.
Also, just coming back!
I'm—I’m so glad that that’s how I
came back.
To the Project for Awesome, to Nerdfighteria
working together to raise over two million dollars.
It’s still going on, by the way, if you
wanna get one of those last-minute perks,
if you watch this within the first twelve
hours of it being up, you can go to projectforawesome.com/donate
and get some stuff.
Obviously thanks to everybody who helped make
this happen, everybody who donated, everybody
who shared it, everybody who voted on videos,
everybody who made videos, all of the volunteers
who put it all together, all of the people
who joined us in the livestream.
Going away for the last six weeks has been
really weird.
I’ve never done it before, never left this
channel in almost ten years of making videos.
And it was a really weird time to do that.
I’m really used to, like, when something
in the world is going on that I want to talk about,
just talking about it, and it was interesting
to take a break from that during a moment
in which everyone really wanted to say some
things.
I think it really changed me, and I’m really
interested to see how that manifests as I
get back into making videos and get a chance
to say some of the things I’ve been thinking about.
We got many more larger donations this year,
so I’m gonna thank a bunch of those people in the description.
We also got a $25,000 matching donation from
YouTube as part of their new Creators for
Change project, which I will link to in the
description.
Basically, YouTube is reaching out with money
to a bunch of different YouTube creators who
are dealing with social issues on their channels.
Creators who are promoting awareness, tolerance,
and empathy with the kind of content that they make.
It’s a really cool program.
Link in the description.
John, thanks so much for doing this with me.
Everybody, thank you for your support of the
Project for Awesome.
projectforawesome.com/donate if you want to
get those last-minute perks.
John, I’ll see you on Monday.